I'm concerned about the way the European
Union is increasingly operating like a
free market across Europe tearing up the
social chapter damaging working class
and workers interests across Europe
hiding tax evasion in Luxembourg and
other places and secretly negotiating a
transatlantic kind of finish secretly
negotiating a transatlantic trade and
investment partnership I think we as a
party need to be making strong demands
of defending and expanding the social
chapter defending and expanding workers
rights across Europe and chasing down
these approved tax havens that exist by
the European Union all across Europe and
asking some serious questions about the
way they've treated the people of Greece
and other countries by their imposition
of austerity measures
while we seem to be strange if you're
out of it and the people who are
undermining the social chapters the tour
is being dragged by there is why the
point I'm making is that Britain ought
to be defending those social gains we as
the Labour Party should be making
demands on this leaving it's a camera to
go away it's a chapter and tear up an
awful lot of environmental protection
and other issues and also the way in
which I think we want a social Europe a
Europe of solidarity what we're in
danger of going with Cameron's
negotiations is a Europe of free market
and very little social